as temperatures drop Netflix and chill
season heats up but with so many steamy
picks on the streamer mindlessly
browsing can be a real mood killer here
are the spiciest movies currently on
offer let's face it historically
speaking most portrayals of sex work on
film especially horror films haven't
been all that great that's just one of
many reasons why the 2018 erotic horror
film cam is such a delightful surprise
this intimate character study of a sex
worker is refreshingly modern and
humanizing making it a unique entry in
the horror film Canon Madeleine Brewer
plays Alice Ackerman the cam girl and
model who performs erotic acts in real
time for an internet audience Alice's
goal is to become the number one model
on the website she calls home a goal she
pursues with an obsessive fervor but one
day Alice discovers she's been locked
out of her account and someone else is
now streaming under her identity but
when she tunes into her own channel to
see who the culprit is she sees herself
or perhaps more specific typically
another woman who looks exactly like her
something about this other woman seems a
bit off perhaps even inhuman is she an
imposter some sort of advanced computer
program or could there perhaps be
something Supernatural afoot
unless skillful hands cam could have
been truly awful but thanks to a
tremendous screenplay by writer Isa Mase
what we get instead is an honest
examination of internet sex work and
freelance hustle culture from an
Insider's perspective not to mention in
unsettling thoroughly original horror
flick how can you maintain a long-term
relationship in an age when technology
has fried attention spans and made
cheating easier than ever that's the
question asked by the 2017 romantic
drama Nunes directed by Drake to Remus
lyacosta and Nicholas Holt play Gabby
and Martin a pair of promiscuous young
people who get together for a quick
little fling after matching on a dating
app though neither was looking for
anything serious before they know it
they end up falling into an intense
relationship although their passions
burn bright for a short while soon that
spark begins to fade in order to once
again recapture that feeling of newness
Gabby and Martin decide for the first
time in both of their lives to attempt
an open relationship the pair enters
into this new arrangement and naively
believing that it will solve all of
their problems only to discover that
there are deeper issues between the two
of them that polyamory alone cannot
solve Nunes is a great looking movie
with two great looking leads but be
warned at no point during this film will
you ever see anything resembling a
healthy and functional relationship
polyamorous or otherwise so don't watch
this one expecting love advice what
you'll get instead is excellent actors
getting naked being moody and making
some terrible decisions so turn down the
lights pour yourself a glass of wine and
drink in every frame of this beautiful
slow motion train wreck if you prefer
your sexy Noir with a Sapphic flavor you
owe it to yourself to check out the 2021
Japanese romantic Thriller ride or die
Rey a lesbian in her late 20s living in
Tokyo gets an unexpected call from her
old high school friend nanaya back in
their school days Rey had a crush on
Anaya but as far as Ray new the Nile is
strict now it seems that nanaya is being
abused by her husband and she wants
Rey's help getting rid of him for good
despite her better judgment Rey agrees
to help and although she succeeds in
knocking off One Eye's husband she also
leaves behind some evidence the two
women realize it's only a matter of time
before they're arrested so they decide
to flee to the Japanese Countryside and
enjoy whatever time they have left
together as they wait for the law to
catch up with them with stunning
cinematography and a meticulously
crafted script ride or die is one hell
of a trip that being said if you're
expecting a Non-Stop pulse-pounding
bloody romp you'll be deeply
disappointed the majority of the runtime
is not filled with sexy violent action
but instead a surprisingly somber story
of two doomed human beings contemplating
their own mortality yes it's a beautiful
story but it's also a profoundly grim
and Melancholy one not for the faint of
heart
if just one sexy story isn't enough for
you how about four lust stories is a
2018 Hindi language comedy drama
Anthology film composed of four short
films each made by a different director
all are primarily about sex and
unusually all have female protagonists
in one story a confident assertive
College teacher has an ill-advised fling
with one of her students at first she
worries that she might lose her job or
that her student might get too clingy
but when neither of these negative
consequences come to pass she soon
realizes that her biggest problems are
her own unexpected feelings of
possessiveness and attachment another
story centers on a maid having a fiery
secret relationship with her employer a
wealthy young Bachelor one day she
learns that she will have to serve tea
for a gathering at her employer's
apartment with guests that include the
young man's parents another young woman
and her family it soon becomes clear
that the purpose of this meeting is to
discuss the possibility of an arranged
marriage and our heroine has to silently
serve both families as the man she loves
plans a future without her some of the
tales told in lust stories are more
comedic and others are more serious but
all of them explore the ways that female
sexual desire comes into conflict with
modern cultural expectations and all of
them do so with Unapologetic honesty the
result is a highly recommended smartly
written emotionally complex Anthology
film there's no way to describe the plot
of the 2016 Noir Thriller Frank and Lola
without it sounding like a cliche
Michael Shannon plays Frank a
middle-class middle-aged Chef in Vegas
his new girlfriend played by Imogen Cruz
is clearly too young and too hot for him
Lola then gets a new job and suddenly
seems awfully cozy with her new boss a
man who is younger cuter and richer than
Frank Frank starts to feel jealous
suspecting that Lola's cheating on him
and Lola tells him that he's just
imagining it then as Frank begins
discovering evidence of her betrayal his
jealousy reaches a boiling point and he
starts thinking violent thoughts you
need your own restaurant
yeah that'd be cool it may sound
unoriginal on the surface but there's
more going on in Frank and Lola than you
might think not a lot more but just
enough you see Lola is indeed lying to
Frank but the truth is much more
complicated than what he suspects as the
film unfolds whenever the plot seems
like it's heading for a predictable
twist it veers away slightly into
unexpected territory whenever the
characters appear to be in danger or
becoming two-dimensional they open up a
little and reveals some hidden Humanity
in the end the film transcends The tired
Noir cliches and ends up being a complex
exploration of Love jealousy and
forgiveness if you want steamy well it
doesn't get much steamier than this
there are countless reasons to love your
name engraved herein it's an expertly
crafted romantic drama that is as tragic
as it is heartwarming it's the most
successful lgbtq film in Taiwanese
history and also the most successful
Taiwanese film of 2020 but most
importantly it's hot as hell the film is
set in Taiwan in the late 80s and
follows two boys who are on the cusp of
graduating from an all-boys Catholic
School one is well-behaved boy who does
his best to blend into the crowd the
other is far more willing to break the
rules the two become fast friends due to
an immediate mutual attraction that
remains unspoken at least at first as
the two get to know each other better
their desire to act on their feelings
only deepens but given the time in which
they live the prospect of an actual
relationship seems like a near
impossibility will the two eventually
part ways or accept their love for one
another regardless of the consequences
with great actors a clever script and a
big vulnerable heart it's hard not to be
Charmed by the low-key romantic comedy
duck butter One Night in a gay bar
struggling actor Naima crosses paths
with the cute singer named Sergio the
two women have an instant connection and
end up spending the night together high
on lust they then concoct a truly
unhinged idea they decide to stay
together for an entire day and night
having sex once an hour for 24 hours
straight the reality of this plan
however ends up being much more
difficult and far less romantic than
they initially thought as Naima and
Sergio end up getting to know a bit too
much about each other a bit too quickly
and end up seeing one another at their
worst just like this has been a lot
for us if you liked Before Sunrise but
thought it needed a lot more sex this
one will probably be your jam though
it's by no means a perfect film 2019's
Elisa and Marcella is certainly a steamy
one Loosely based on actual historical
events the film begins in the late 1800s
in its School in Spain a new student
arrives the shy Marcella and she
immediately attracts the attention of
the more assertive and carefree Elisa
what starts as a friendship then
blossoms into a secret romance as years
pass and the woman move on into
adulthood their relationship continues
always in the dark behind closed doors
but nothing good can last forever and
eventually their secret is discovered
Elisa decides to disappear for a while
and then returns with a new identity
disguising herself as a man named Mario
the two were then able to get married
but yet again this is not the end of
their troubles it would be nice to give
this film an enthusiastic unqualified
recommendation but unfortunately as the
film's rather unimpressive Rotten Tomato
score shows this one isn't exactly a
masterpiece most of it is a bit too slow
and Moody for its own good and whenever
a big dramatic scene happens it Trends
towards the melodramatic if you love a
good lesbian period romance and you've
already watched portrait of a lady on
fire and the handmaiden a dozen times
each consider giving Elisa and Marcela a
watch
sex crime and hotel management Collide
in the controversial 2020 polish film
365 days based on the first of a Trilogy
of erotic novels the title refers to the
unusual year-long courtship between
Laura a beautiful Warsaw hotelier
trapped in a Loveless and sexless
relationship and Massimo the volatile
and seductive leader of an Italian crime
family after a chance meeting at a
sicilian Resort Massimo drugs and
kidnaps Laura he reveals that they had
met once five years earlier on the day
his father was murdered and that he's
been obsessed with her ever since he
plans to hold her captive for 365 days
or until she falls in love with him what
follows is an hour or so of delayed
gratification Massimo forces Laura into
any number of provocative situations
without actually forcing himself on her
Laura for her part alternates between
trying to escape her captor and enjoying
the Luck's life of a mafioso's kept
woman before finally coming to his
unconventional Arrangement Netflix
adapted the other two novels in the
trilogy in 2022 365 days this day and
the next 365 days the tortured love
story of Tessanne Hardin continues in
after we collided the 2020 sequel to
2019's after the film finds Josephine
langford's Tessa out of college and
interning at a big city publishing house
while Hardin played by Hero finds Tiffin
is still kicking around their college
town after she drunk dials him in the
middle of the night the two once again
enter each other's orbit fighting having
sex reconciling breaking up and then
getting back together over and over
again much to the confusion and Chagrin
of everyone else who knows them author
Anna Todd famously based the afternovels
on her One Direction fan fiction where
she imagined the members of the British
boy band as college students in the
Pacific Northwest bad boy Hardin is
naturally based on Harry Styles after we
collided expands the world Beyond just
Tessa and her garden and their immediate
friends and classmates throwing in a
good amount of intrigue regarding their
parents and the sins of the past
The Art of Loving is the literal
translation of shtuka kohanya the
Revolutionary 1978 book on sexual
practices by polish sexologist
michaelino weslowska and the title of
the 2017 biopic starring Magdalena
bacharska as wasloka the film hops
across the Decades of dysloka's life and
work from her efforts to build a life in
post-war Poland with her male and female
lovers to fighting against the communist
government of the 1970s to getting her
book published befitting the story of a
sex researcher the nudity and eroticism
in the film are often very Frank and
sometimes comically deadpan in their
depictions director Maria sotomska
doesn't shy away from the ways that
sexuality can be used for violence and
oppression as in an early flashback
where magdalena's lover Wanda is forced
to have sex with a Nazi officer still
the film like the book is ultimately a
celebration of love and lovemaking in
one scene visloca shouts at a pair of
male party officials it's a user's
manual don't you get it these are just
two of the seemingly endless parade of
many who are threatened to their core by
what the Art of Loving represents
butcherska is marvelous as vizloka
playing her seamlessly across the
decades as she seeks to help people not
just have better sex but to make better
connections with one another we should
all be so lucky to have our first blush
of Love during a summer spent in the
Italian Countryside Luka guagadino's
acclaimed 2017 film call me by your name
is set amongst the beauty and ruins of
Northern Italy in 1983 where American
Professor Mr Perlman lives with his wife
and 17 year old son Elio one 24 year old
grad student Oliver comes to stay with
the pearlmans for the summer his
presence awakens something in Elio
though both young men pursue
relationships with women in these short
months it's clear that their greatest
affections are for each other based on a
novel by Andreas and featuring a
screenplay by James Ivory the film has a
lot going on under the surface questions
of identity abound obviously regarding
Elio and Oliver's sexuality but also in
relation to their religion both men are
Jewish but Oliver's blonde complexion
allows him to pass more easily some
elements are intended to make audiences
uneasy such as the age difference
between Oliver and Elio as well as Mr
perlman's quiet approval of the
relationship the confession of an erotic
fantasy sends a Manhattan doctor reeling
in 1999's Eyes Wide Shut the final film
of Stanley Kubrick Dr Bill harford's
world is shattered when his wife Alice
tells him that a non-sexual encounter
with a naval officer the year before
stirred such strong desire in her that
she considered leaving Bill and their
children taking this as a rebuke of
their marital vows and his sexual
prowess Bill leaves their New York
apartment and stalks a nearly empty City
what follows is a picaresque journey
through Bill's insecurities as he
encounters a sex worker a provocative
teenager an old friend who works at a
piano bar and most famously an orgy at a
mansion
password so
fidelity Kubrick based the film on
Arthur schnitzler's 1926 novel dream
story moving the action to modern day
America but keeping schnitzler's focus
on dreams sexuality and the subconscious
Kubrick added to the dreamlike Quality
by not filming in New York but rather on
a massive London Sound Stage designed to
look like Greenwich Village and by
casting a very famous real life couple
Cruz and Kidman as Bill and Alice the
iconic orgy sequence used dancers in
choreography that was non-explicit but
sensuous and surreal still the film was
threatened with an NC-17 rating and CGI
Figures were added to some shots to
obscure the view of some scandalous
moments the 2011 Indy a good
old-fashioned orgy fits neatly into the
late 2000s trend of raunchy
improvisation heavy comedies about man
children finally learning to grow up
like the 40 year old virgin or knocked
up Eric is a grown man who has been
throwing ragers at his family's Vacation
House in the Hamptons since he was a
teenager when his father announces that
he's selling the house Eric is inspired
to throw one last party an honest to
goodness sex-filled orgy for all of his
childhood friends I'm putting the house
on the market what about me I'm always
out here my friends are always out here
the film is refreshingly tight and well
structured for being from a comedy era
known for its bloated run times clocking
in at just 95 minutes also rare for the
era that too often depicted its female
characters as humorless killjoys the
women of the cast are allowed to be as
immature and funny as the men when it
comes to the titular orgy the film
follows through on the premise committed
to not just the sex but also the
emotional complications that can come
with it in the end new bonds are forged
and lessons are learned not least of
which is that pool water is not a good
lubricant D.H Lawrence's classic novel
comes to life once again in the 2022
Netflix adaptation of Lady Chatterley's
Lover Emma Corin of the crown plays
Connie the young wife of an English
aristocrat who grows fresh traded and
lonely when her husband returns from
World War one injured and impotent
wandering the grounds of her husband's
estate lady chatterley meets and falls
into a passionate affair with gamekeeper
Oliver their Love Burns bright and hot
but the difference in their stations
means they can never truly be together
the novel and the film are about
transgressions of All Sorts not just the
affair between Connie and Oliver Oliver
is also married though estranged from
his wife who refuses to give him a
divorce Connie's husband Clifford
understanding that he can't satisfy his
young wife due to his injuries gives her
implicit permission to step outside
their marriage but is aghast that she's
chosen a man so below her class for a
lover in many ways Connie's sensuous
betrayal of the strict British caste
system of the era is the greatest
transgression of all
places starting to lose its charm don't
you think Matthew Duncan and Jack
O'Connell are both fine as the somewhat
hapless man in Connie's orbit but corn
keeps the film afloat along with Jolie
Richardson as a sympathetic housekeeper
Netflix has the 2021 French biopic about
famed brothel keeper Madame Claude rated
tvma for among other things nudity sex
and smoking there is certainly a lot of
smoking as the film luxuriates in its
mid-century Paris setting and all the
glamor that implies Coral Rocher stars
as the eponymous but I'm Claude perhaps
the most famous brothel owner of the
20th century at least in France clothes
supplied high-end escorts and discretion
to the world's wealthy Elite for decades
her list of clients apparently included
John F Kennedy Omar Gaddafi and actor
Marlon Brando among many others the film
charts the beginning of the end from
Adam Claude who fled France in the
mid-1970s over tax evasion charges when
a cultured young woman named sidoni
applies to be one of Madame clothes
workers clothes sees her as the ticket
to a higher Echelon of French society
however sidoni is no stepping stone and
her behavior casts an unwanted light on
the entire operation eventually leading
to the fall of clothes Empire the first
two-thirds of the film examine the
perils and pleasures of sex work
accompanied by hip Fashions and an
effortlessly cool soundtrack of French
pop songs before a rushed ending Recaps
the final Decades of clothes long life
in minutes Rocher is simultaneously
imperious and Charming as the title
character though even she can't help but
get overshadowed by the 1970s production
design every so often the life and
tragic death of French diver Andre mest
is dramatized in the 2022 film No Limit
Camille Rose stars as Master stand in
Roxanna a talented College age swimmer
Who falls under the spell of both the
sport of freediving and one of its Stars
the handsome Pascal the film's version
of real life diver Pepin ferreiras
Roxanna joins Pascal's team first as an
assistant then as a competitor herself
and then after Pascal leaves the
competitive world to become roxanna's
coach a star in her own right the film
directed by David M Rosenthal plays fast
and loose with the facts of Master's
life and death and overall is less
interested in roxanna's athleticism than
with her palpable sexual chemistry with
Pascal throughout the script hints at
roxanna's impending accidental death in
ways that can feel exploitative her
professor warns of the dangerous
pressures at deep ocean depths a rescue
diver on Pascal's team dies nearly the
same way Roxanna will and during one of
their many spirited lovemaking sessions
Pascal puts his hand around roxanna's
throat to choke her Roe does what she
can with the role but the film's
emphasis on her affair with Pascal makes
her feel less of a driven athlete and
more like a girl who followed a boy into
the water Ophelia opens all of her
Stone's 2012 crime drama with some very
eyebrow racing narration
orgasms
he has orgasms she's referring to her
boyfriend chunk a veteran who runs
lucrative marijuana business with
Ophelia and her other boyfriend Ben
things are going well for the sun-kissed
uncommonly beautiful thrupple until
their Enterprise grows a little too big
and draws the attention of a Mexican
cartel on the other side of the Border
when Ben and Sean refuse cartel
Lieutenant lotto's offer of a
partnership the cartel kidnaps Ophelia
in retaliation suddenly the two best
friends are thrust into the brutal world
of cartel Warfare where they must go to
uncommon lengths to rescue their shared
girlfriend if that orgasm's line didn't
tip you off this is not a subtle film it
is however an exciting one Stone Works
in the hyperkinetic visual style of
Natural Born Killers with a dash of
Latin American politics from his
breakthrough feature Salvador Stone has
a lot of ideas about the damage wrought
by the American war machine whether in
Afghanistan or on the streets of Juarez
foreign
[Music]